regardez le il est trop mignon un petit
bijou technologique
je suis très heureux d'accueillir à la
maison kicker
[Musique]
mais c'est super content ça fait trois
mois que j'ai un produit trois mois que
j'ai envie de vous en parler puis j'ai
attendait parce que je voulais vraiment
le connaître par coeur pour pouvoir vous
en parler autant aux smartphones c'est
plus évident j'ai l'habitude il ya des
vraies différences entre certains
smartphones certains demandent plus de
temps de prise en main que d'autres mais
là ce produit il demandait vraiment
vraiment vraiment une vraie belle
connaissances solides 30 beaucoup de
temps pour pouvoir vous en parler je
suis super content j'ai super hâte c'est
un robot c'est un robot qui s'appelle
kicker qu'a développée par une marque
française par une entreprise française
je suis hyper enthousiaste parce que
vous allez voir ce robot il complètement
ouf
il a une vraie belle place dans notre
foyer et vous allez voir ce qu'on peut
faire avec mais juste avant je vous
montre quelque chose première chose ça
la lampe tout nouveau alors ça c'est une
idée de mon fils un promo pour mon
anniversaire il a dit va papa va lui
mettre un joli qui activent dans son
bureau donc on a une toute nouvelle
lampe cactus dites moi ce que vous en
pensez est ce que vous trouvez que ça va
bien avec le reste on va y avoir pas mal
de modifications dans le studio et pas
mal de choses qui vont changer
dites moi comment vous la trouvez ça
tient pas qu'à regarder ce qu'on a
reçues aussi en colis aujourd'hui ça
c'est un truc de ouf
hyper content on va parler de photos
parce qu'on parle pas beaucoup de photos
et pourtant il ya vachement de choses
cool à dire c'est un appareil la marque
c'est lomographie or c'est un appareil
un peu à l'ancienne ça vous sort des
clichés instantanés donc là on a pas mal
de choses à tester
on a des filles on à du papier
je vais recevoir un autre collie
normalement demain avec encore un peu
plus de matos et là vous allez voir ça
va être cool et ça pour la fête de fin
d'année franchement ça va déchirer grave
je suis prêt si vous avez gardé dans son
studio ça devient un peu tout et
n'importe quoi en terme de maintenance
ya tellement de trucs que je me retrouve
pas là entre une moto une trottinette
électrique entre offres de tomber
aujourd'hui entre toutes ces choses là
est juste là il est là il est beau il
est chaud voici tic
aujourd'hui c'est une journée un peu
particulière ici dans cette boîte vous
avez un nouveau membre de la famille
certains prennent des chiens des chats
nous on a décidé de prendre un robot je
vous présente donc la boîte de notre
nouveau compagnon c'est kicker l'idée là
tout de suite là maintenant c'est
l'ouvrir de sortir voir un peu ce qu'il
ya dedans dans quelques jours je vais
continuer la vidéo dont je n'ai pas
fabriqué généraux venir à quelques jours
pour comprendre comment ça marche
à quoi sert kicker à quoi nous servent
les robots qu'est ce qui peut nous
apporter et en quoi ce robot qui a été
dessiné penser en france et coup et ça
c'est cool parce que ça me permet de
voir que l'entreprise française son top
au niveau de l'high-tech la fabrique des
robots
c'est génial bravo je suis hyper content
parce que c'est un peu un rêve de gamin
je sais pas vous mais moi gamin je
rêvais d'avoir un robot compagnie mais
c'était de la science fiction il à la
section l hiver
so happy to meet you tube smile homme s
j'ai l'impression de découvrir r2d2
salut kicker bienvenue à la maison
regardez le il est trop mignon
oh la vache c'est génial j'ai trop hâte
de le mettre en service voir comment ça
marche havas un petit bijou
technologique
je suis très heureux d'accueillir à la
maison kicker
je suis pas faire ça va mieux comme ça
voilà qui coeur alors kickers un petit
robot c'est un robot intelligent c'est
pas juste un petit robot qui est là pour
vous tenir compagnie pour l présent dire
deux trois trucs au kicker il un vrai
vrai vrai vrai sens c'est une vraie
machine qui est bourré de technologie si
je vous disais une entreprise française
qui l'a développé gd rencontrés il ya pa
très très longtemps
le début qui coeur c'était une fois
encore j'ai vu c'était ça et ça va
grincer ces théories mais c'était
vraiment dans le
c'est vrai et après on est parti sur un
autre les plus grands la bave presse est
ce ici donc beaucoup plus gros tellement
à l'intérieur c'était pas très joli mais
file plein de câbles on a voulu c'est
énorme
simplifier oui c'était énorme les 22 km
es22 kg le grec ça c'est deux kilos et
demi à chaque jour parce que c'était du
plastique club est fait à la main et que
ça et c'était des premiers crs 2014
d'accord et après on a
un autre proto qui est pas là parce
qu'il n'était jamais vraiment utilisable
sas et 2015 et en 2016 on a fait ce
premier pas qui était quasi industrielle
et à partir de celui-ci
on a dix années
et dernièrement protection qu'il ya là
c'est un vidéoprojecteur vous pouvez
projetées sur un mur à un mètre
cinquante de recul à ça vous fera une
diagonale de 2 mètres je voulais vous
montrer ça d'ici quelques instants vous
est carrément vous reculez et là ça nous
fera un grand grand grand grand écran
beaucoup plus grand que ce que tu peux
avoir vécu un truc complètement
officines et surtout ce qui est génial
c'est que la caméra elle est
complètement orientable le
vidéoprojecteur bouge c'est moi qui
choisis où je le mets je choisis
l'inclinaison j'ai choisi comme enjeu
veulent orienter et vous permet de
mettre des images au plafond ce qui fait
que lorsque vous avez regardé votre film
dans le salon voulait compter sur lui en
avait marre il tombera dès la fin du
film dans le lit vous êtes dans votre
chambre vous mettez kicker il projette
au plafond vous êtes touchés j'ai plus
qu'à vous endormir c'est juste c'est
difficile
là je suis dans ma chambre j'ai envie de
me regarder un film gens ils me posaient
alors ce que je vais faire déjà vu dans
la lumière voilà on va moins bien
je me couche sur mon lit tranquille j'ai
envie de finir ma petite soirée en me
regardant un film pénale j'ai commencé à
regarder de l'autre côté dans mon salon
je fais quoi
eh bien regardez hop je regarde star
wars directement au plafond et
croyez-moi royer sticker est juste là au
bout de la pièce y projette moi je suis
là j'ai plus qu'à regarder star wars et
franchement je suis au top vous pouvez
projeté en 1080i lit en 720p luminosité
cdu mis lui même ce depuis vingt mille
heures de visionnage ne fait pas
beaucoup de bruit il fait moins de 25
d'ici mais ça c'est le bruit qui court
j'ai vraiment mis le micro contre c'est
du 25 décibels on trouve aussi belle ça
fait pas beaucoup de bruit de ta taille
de l'image vous allez 52 cm à 3 159 cm
je peux encore agrandir complètement
complètement complètement à grandir ça
dépend après vraiment vraiment la taille
de votre pièce les voyez là sur une
distance de couach une distance de 3 m
je peux faire un truc énorme et je peux
encore reculé kicker là j'ai reculé
kicker et là c'est pareil c'est juste
énorme ce que je peux faire
alors ça dépend bien évidemment de votre
maison ça dépend ce que vous voulez vous
voyez la chaîne une distance qui est
quand même beaucoup plus proche on est
quoi l on est un maître un maître en
médecin quand ça vous permet d'avoir du
contenu multimédia quelle que soit la
distance vous adaptez complètement votre
maison ce qui ouvre complètement ouf
c'est l'audio
vous voyez il ya du fond je vais pousser
à fond pendant fort longtemps
vous allez voir ça lui sinon
c'est très très très très très très fort
vous allez jusqu'à 117 décibels prévenez
vos voisins ils vont partir en courant
parce que c'est extrêmement fort si vous
pousser à fond le sont cent dix sept
décibels c'est nantes par contre la
qualité elle est complètement dingue
vous avez quatre haut parleurs fond
orange de 10 watts ça marche super bien
et vous avez un caisson de basses de 50
watts moi j'ai été surpris quand je
l'allumé au début je les prix j'ai mis
la vidéo je me suis regardé une série
j'ai halluciné
la qualité du son alors ce qu'on
pourrait lui reprocher c'est que lorsque
vous allez positionnez vous avez une
seule source si vous avez 4 hp ça
diffuse d'une seule source donc on n'a
pas la même sensation d'immersion que si
vous aviez 1,5 point où ce que vous
voulez par contre la qualité la
restitution audio est complètement
bluffante
kika pour la vie mais vous avez derrière
un petit bout de temps juste là si vous
entendez les en train de se ravitailler
lie à kicker qui vient de se réveiller
il a allumé le vidéo proche maintenant
il n'y a plus qu'à attendre les ordres
vous avez votre appui vous pouvez régler
ici l'orientation lemaitre plus au plus
bas vont choisir de mettre netflix par
exemple si vous voulez
là c'est les dessins animés de mon fils
le clash peut lancer ce que je veux ta
par exemple on va se mettre quoi les
lapins crétins up lecture et là ça met
directement mon dessin animé c'est hyper
intuitif je me déplace uniquement avec
mon petit pavé comme ça tactile dessus
je peux aussi naviguer comme ça
directement sur les boutons ou alors
j'ai carrément accès ici au clavier si
vous tapez des choses donc ça c'est
franchement hyper cool [ __ ] vous avez
vraiment le choix et youtube est
inscrite c'est pour cast est ce que vous
voulez ce soit cana plus aux compagnies
vous avez google assistant bien
évidemment vous avez votre télé vous
pouvez piloter votre maison là vous
voyez la température c'est pas très très
chaud tout de suite 18,9 à la maison
alors je pense à monter un petit peu le
chauffage j'ai un taux d'humidité de 58%
donc là j'ai maté les netflix mais
galerie photos je peux piloter
directement de la même manière
mes films et séries avec google play
google paye pour jouer à des jeux ça
c'est cool j'ai google play music donc
là c'est pareil ils peuvent écouter
toute la musique que je veux par exemple
on a un abonnement nous netflix donc
netflix il est en natif directement sur
flickr
donc ça me met directement mais on a
aussi un abonnement canal+ tablette
tablettes et smartphones pas du tout sur
la télé donc techniquement là dessus
canal+ pour l'instant dans les
applications ne l'est pas mais gelé par
contre directement sur mon téléphone et
c'est là où ça devient hyper hyper
intéressant je vais lancer mon appli
canal là je me suis mis star wars et
star wars voudrait bien mettre sur
kicker ce que j'ai à faire je clique ici
ça ne trouve kicker en haut je clique en
turquie coeur et là je pars de mon
application canal+ avec une diffusion
directement sur flickr donc kicker me
permet de regarder directement
toutes mes séries tous mes films de
canal directement là et ça c'est cool
parce que je peux castex énormément de
choses ensuite il coeur vous avez des
caméras vous avez une petite caméra qui
est situé ici à l'avancé une caméra de 5
mégapixels qui vous servira lorsque vous
allez vous déplacer vous allez sur le
sucre caméras sont dits de 13 mégapixels
c'est un fisheye qui me servira à voir à
360 degrés je peut activer les caméras
caméra frontale caméra à 360 degrés ça
c'est la caméra frontale je peux ensuite
passé un petit coup de fil directement
sur kicker il me voilà là c'est ma
tronche dans le téléphone vous voyez là
c'est en train de filmer et là hop est
en train de partir notre côté donc
lorsque vous voulez faire la
visioconférence faire quelque chose de
professionnel ou juste parler à votre
famille lorsque vous êtes loin vous avez
votre appli kicker je peux piloter mon
kicker ce qui est fait dans ma maison je
peux me balader voir un petit peu où je
suis voir ce que je fais donc ça c'est
cool et ensuite j'ai la caméra à 360
degrés qui est sur le dessus de kicker
je peux me déplacer regarder tout autour
de moi inscrire autre point qui percute
kicker et collez votre maison parce
qu'il va complètement cartographier
votre intérieur c'est une des premières
choses à faire lorsque vous aller
l'installer vous à lui faire faire un
tour complet de votre barak lui faire
passer vers les murs lui grâce à ses
capteurs et 14 caméras à 360 degrés il
va repérer les murs les obstacles et
forment des pièces il va complètement
pour cartographier votre pièce ça
typiquement c'est la maison kicker sait
exactement où il est il sait où est sa
base de recharge il peut y aller tout
seul
vous pouvez lui mettre des points
d'intérêt par exemple en lui dit qu'un
là tout installe ici dans le salon c'est
l'endroit idéal tu mets de telle manière
le vidéoprojecteur at-elle auteurs actel
focus vous avez mémoriser tout ça en un
seul et même point vous lui dites kicker
vaste pour l'intérêt il y va il va
projeter comme vous le voulez et ça
franchement c'est hyper hyper cool de la
même manière vous allez complètement
créé toutes les pièces de votre maison
donc vous pouvez lui dire kicker va dans
le savon kicker va dans la chantier ça
pour lui parler c'est hyper simple il
suffit de dire heikki coeur va dans le
salon il y va il est malin il comprend
toujours d'ailleurs il a compris là il
en train de partir ce qu'ils écoulaient
kickers et qui repère les obstacles il
étrangement bénin il a plein de capteurs
autour de lui il sait où il va et si ce
pays va s'arrêter
bon voilà je vais un peu déplacé de
façon sauvage donc ce fut un peu paumé
en a il faut pas le portel vous laisser
se dépasser tout seul et il retrouve son
chemin tout seul comme un moment là il
cherche la solution il a des capteurs de
proximité ce qui fait qu'il va pas
contre les murs il repère les obstacles
ça franchement c'est hyper cool kicker
est complètement autonome
[Musique]
il fonctionne en wifi aussi en bluetooth
4 points 1 sur ios sur android et en
termes de performance vous êtes un
qualcomm snapdragon 820 quatre coeurs
cadencés jusqu'à 2,2 giguère ce vous
avez à 3 giga de ram il est dispo ce
soit en 32 go de stockage soit en 160
gigas de stockage
j'ai aussi mes alarme ma veilleuse m'a
pas trop de la patrouille lorsque je
veux qu'ils surveillent la maison je
peux créer une nouvelle patrouille
je vais lui dire tu va visiter de telle
heure à telle heure une fois en
plusieurs fois telle pièce tu vas
acheter un petit coup d'oeil je lui
créant gros des programmes pour aller
vérifier que je suis pas la faire
tourner la maison c'est plutôt pas mal
et dès qu'un problème il à m'envoyer des
infos l'autonomie en une batterie 12 ans
perd heures franchement si jamais eu
aucun problème
en plus ce qui est cool c'est que tuteur
il est très intelligent donc déclenché
il ya plus de batterie il a tout seul
sur sa base de surcharger donc du coup
vous utilisez la journée ils se
rechargent là ni vous verrez quasiment
pas se vider ou de regarder des films
des séries pendant six heures donc
franchement vous êtes vraiment
tranquille et en plus de ça vous pouvez
le piloter avec google assistant avec
amazon alexa et kicker s'il vous
intéresse vous aime bien lien en
barriques août 1790 euros et vous allez
voir ce qu'on peut faire avec c'est
juste bleus sont les quelques jours ya
la voix de kicker qui arrivait il peut
vous réponds ça c'est cool
il ya aussi un autre application qui va
arriver qui va être mise à jour très
très très rapidement c'est le tactile
sur vos murs vous allez pouvoir toucher
et modifié ce crowley mais aussi la
fonction follow me qui va arriver d'ici
quelques jours vous vous déplacez laker
suis-moi kicker vous suit il va venir
avec vous dans la cuisine dans la
chambre on peut faire ce que vous voulez
mais ça c'est cool enfin voilà ce qui
est vraiment intéressant c'est que comme
ce robot il est bardé de capteurs il ya
des caméras
il ya des micros quelle vidéo prend
vraiment plein de choses ça veut dire
que à l'avenir il ya plein de nouvelles
fonctionnalités qui vont arriver et
kicker au final c'est pas seulement en
robot vidéo projecteur qui fait de la
musique qui peut vous réveillez sûr que
surveiller votre maison vous faire de la
visio contre c'est vraiment un robot
évolutif maintenant point négatif de
kickers et que si vous avez une maison
avec des escaliers
ça n'a pas le faire il va pas être
capable de monter des escaliers ce n'est
pas un robot des gens c'est un robot
roulettes c'est une vraie belle
innovation ça montre un petit peu là où
on va aller au niveau de la robotique la
robotique domestique avec des robots qui
vont prendre une place beaucoup plus
importante alors là on n'est pas sur un
robot intelligent kicker il applique ce
qu'on lui dit il suit les commandes mais
il est pas intelligent mais c'est un peu
là où on va aller à terme si vous voulez
au niveau de la robotique c'est c'est de
se dire que des robots comme kicker vont
finir par avoir une intelligence
artificielle et vont pouvoir communiquer
avec eux mais comment les sur une petite
boîte à taille humaine
ils peuvent pas développer de
l'intelligence artificielle en même
temps mettre en place de nouvelles
fonctionnalités qui doivent faire des
choix ils peuvent pas dans toutes ces
directions d'autant plus une vraie
intelligence artificielle ça demande des
coûts de recherche développement qui
sont complètement énorme mais ça c'est
des choses
à terme on va y arriver d'une manière ou
d'une autre vers 1 d'ici quelques années
c'est une certitude
des robots comme kicker avec qui on va
pouvoir parler d'une manière fluide qui
vont être intelligent qui vont
comprendre nos besoins qui vont y
répondre et qui vont être vraiment
productif
il nous faut encore un peu de patience
mais d'ici là si vous voulez en robots
domestiques qui a une vraie place à
prendre en terme d' usage kicker et
franchement content et je peux vous
invite à le découvrir si vous intéresse
d'ailleurs je vous ai mis un lien en bas
dans la description et dites moi vous ce
que vous en pensez quand vous trouvez
déjà cette solution qui courait ce que
vous trouvez que le robot écouler ce que
vous trouvez intéressant ce petit à r2d2
est-ce que vous pensez que la robotique
va falloir une place prédominante dans
nos foyers
est ce que vous pensez qu'on va voir de
plus en plus de robots c'est vraiment un
sujet hyper hyper hyper hyper
passionnant tout cas moi j'y crois
vraiment petit coeur je le trouve cool
je continue à faire plein de cession et
puis mon fils est très heureux parce que
je lui ai danses et chants quoi ah c'est
les dessins animés s'émerveiller voilà
bon vous marquez tout ça on reste
connectés on va parler de plein de
choses la robotique on va reparler d'ici
quelques jours
ocs à vegas souci d'aller voir un petit
peu ce qui se trame ce qui se passe
et puis il ya plein d'autres sujets
hyper cool donc je vous invite à vous
abonner voilà soyez sages à très bientôt
ciao